hey what up it's your boy Pete to the
paw up in this hacky nests crib
look at those fairy lights what is is a
YouTube video disgust me
British vlogger love them they're the
best that's why I Spit let's talk to
plastic more like bullaiah
blast it Oh around the Sky City enclosed
environmental protocols for a while but
they shut down the whole system after
more like boring me to death vast ik
okay what do you got you could help me
access the medical ward the medic brain
of course the medic are look great but
only accessible by public gales consists
of information and communication too
sensitive to risk propagation on the
regular grid how do we article on I've
met from geolocation what is she talking
about if you could tap into those nexus
points I can assemble them to get black
I have no idea what you can Thank You G
says once he breached the first point
there's safety protocols with race -
[ __ ] lat you need to reach all the
points before that happens okay I got it
I think why do they always have to do
that just feed you a bunch of
mumbo-jumbo and be like Adam just good
just go to point a from point B that's
all you need to do I already forgot the
controls we're going this way supposedly
how the [ __ ] am I supposed to go there
are you crazy
we're going for it oh my god went a
little far denied
I really missed that cracking sound I
know I keep saying it but that cracking
sound when you hit the concrete like
it's beautiful what are you scared while
you remove satisfied oh my god there was
glass here are you [ __ ] kidding me
man
god there's so much in this world people
complain that there's not enough in the
game but I I feel like there's so much
compared to the first one like yeah oh
my god boxes
hey you landed in the water huh Mirror's
Edge is the kind of game like if you
play it too much they'll leak into your
real life and when you start running
your real hey guys please I'm telling a
story I get in a sock uh kind of like
when you play to my Sonic and you have
to go to a place a little fast and you
just gotta go like really fast and you
spray your hair hair blue and you
realize that you're never you'll never
be a hedgehog this is a relatable story
to anyone don't care let's just take the
quest cool capture all the encrypted
leaks here we go
gotta go fast I will come on yeah got it
only few left of this data clouds am i
right
oh I did not just do that jump come on
Oh sick yeah haha ah
yes that was cool man hey taste my shoe
thank you very much all right we need to
check our map we're supposed to go
others why we got to run all that way
are you kidding me
RIT is rife with air we go so we're
bleeding alright that took him on the
neck a bobble friend they have
super-powered enemies laughing I'm
getting mine jump whoa wait oh oh hey oh
she never stops look at that
go faith faith what the [ __ ] are you
doing why is it so [ __ ] complicated
to get to the damn lair I said I
understand that it's supposed to be like
hitting it [ __ ] but [ __ ] man here we are
hey how's it goin everyone hey it's my
babe hey how you doin that's right let's
talk to Noah [ __ ] yeah
you started this no we've been talking
about nice trouble the bobble by the way
winning the employees huh you're a
psychopath
baby you always were yeah Rebecca if you
have took a stance on anything Noah I
might care about your favorite oh thank
you when you come to your senses that is
if it happens before Kruger catches up
to you
faith you've grown barely out of prison
and already stirring things up your
parents would be proud oh oh
her parents are dead how dare you say
that whatever was he stole from there he
was doing steal Rebecca Thane
the leader of black November shooting my
parents yeah we were all part of the
same Hooper forward anyway
Rebecca was always a breed apart she
thinks he can change the world like
blowing it up faith
she wanted the omnis dad dr blueprint on
it
why don't give it to her because in her
own way she's as dangerous as gabriel
krueger in her own way guys flexures
obviously more than the conglomerate
will admit and I have a feeling Rebecca
should be kept away from it good because
I was gonna offer to Dogen
I tell you well tonight not to take
sides
I do take sides Arcite yeah oh [ __ ] you
do not just have put that thing man
what nevermind I'll see you soon
faith we didn't actually finish faith
you actually let me do my turn as always
what if we go back to him and be like
hey what what was it what do you want to
tell me oh sorry I didn't know you were
so fascinated by my feet look at my feet
look um all right let's go on our next
mission [ __ ] am I supposed to get there
here we go talk to the benefactor how
you doin nice glances Donny you don't
look happy let her in Hey
to think you should humble me with a
visit I'm sorry I should have come
sooner far be it for me to judge it's
not like you owe me anything
look about that I've got something to
score my debt with don't be crude I
haven't seen you in two years and
already you're talking about debt come
machines make perfect food what a
perfection is boring
it's the imperfections that truly make
something unique oh the tattoo
occasionally introduced a human touch a
little imperfection you still have it I
thought I'd get rid of it I almost did
you made me very angry faith
one could almost say it your specialty
considering the extent to which you've
recently aggrieved mr. Kruger he is out
for runner blood whatever it is you
stole from him must be very valuable
it's the blueprint for reflection ah and
you have it with you not right now and
we will discuss your debt when you do in
the meantime I believe a show of good
faith is in order
pardon the pun huh Anansi have been
remiss with their payments a little
human touch should set them straight all
right I get it
what do you need go to the Anansi
Emporium
I will update you along the way um I'm
thinking more and more this is a prequel
but I don't think I understand you know
cuz she doesn't have to tattoo you know
what I mean hey what do we got some
upgrade Thanks okay I get to try it
right away okay and we're pulling up
that was fast
not as fast as sanic though boom
yeah look at me go
so fast come on faith you can go faster
hey I can go up here that's cool I'm not
even sure if I'm supposed to go here I'm
gonna die what it means to them oh come
on I could have done that jump let's do
a time trail it's been a while okay wait
what a start
oh well I can't do that jump are you
[ __ ] kidding me yeah zero stars
one star whoa holy [ __ ] come on come on
free stars damn it two stars two stars I
can totally do it
I can totally do [ __ ] it's so hard ah
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] how the [ __ ] is
that possible
Oh [ __ ] sake man no [ __ ] you go off
you [ __ ] come on No oh [ __ ] that cost
me the [ __ ] Tsar oh you [ __ ]
kidding me one tiny little piece of
Tom's fear how about you thumbs for wave
[ __ ] god damn it
go I lost it how do you fall from that
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me [ __ ] this [ __ ]
race then [ __ ] you [ __ ] everyone god
[ __ ] damn it piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god I'm gonna do it [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah I did it that's right
[ __ ] yeah you thought I
couldn't do it did you
three stars three stars [ __ ] I
perfected that [ __ ]
number one in the world number one I'm
the king I'm the [ __ ] King I'm the
world record-breaking by the [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] y'all haters sorry I got
a little too emotional that was [ __ ]
awesome though now let's go there oh
well look a dirt look at that so that's
how you get a pun you [ __ ] lying son
of a [ __ ] how do I get up get up get up
get out of my head
I love these puzzle parts it's really
fun there's one part in the original
Mirror's Edge where I literally got
stuck and I could not figure out how to
get further you know what I'm talking
about you know what I'm oh there's
something really atmospheric about it
just look around in this world look at
that [ __ ] crazy man oh snap
oh my lord that was amazing
where the hell am i oh my god holy [ __ ]
sorry guys that wasn't important
oh hell yeah yeah oh my god so epic look
at the beautiful scenery and [ __ ] aren't
you excited
hey eh that's too excited man what the
[ __ ] the matter with you
put your pants back on [ __ ] weirdo
where's his [ __ ] fire alarm then huh
wait ahead Oh slide
I love the vent times event times is the
best man oh boy am i enjoying the vent
time
feel like a little rant if TV be the
pivot it's the sound of rats thank you
very much alright this is the fire alarm
OOP that's how you activate a fire alarm
caution fire here we go and we take the
elevator not suspicious as bad matter
all-together what survived Emily
of course intrigue finds the balance I
still don't understand the story it's
the same problem with the first game
look at the view of this scenery that's
a word whoa look at that I'm doing my
I'm enjoying myself
whoa everything will go fine what
discussion Oh shortcut oh my god sick oh
my God we're so high up Jesus Christ is
giving me [ __ ] oh I feel sick Jesus I
want to play this game of the oculist oh
my god
oh my god faith what are you doing
the [ __ ] are you doing oh that's it baby
this is awesome I am enjoying myself
all right we're going hiring guys
where's the damn party no thing that
should be right in front of you it's not
now why didn't you just say that it's a
crazy huge pendulum because things
should be called better properties
now you need to dislodge it there should
be three support clamps for you did he
activate okay one gotta sleep Eddy
yeah Paradis this is so [ __ ] awesome
I love this big sound effect of me
running
don't worry about it another corner
thing yeah double thing jump oh hey okay
number two yeah yeah where's the last
this way of course jump on the giant
black thing that seemed safe
Oh God it's not safe oh my god that was
amazing this is really cool I'm Rick I'm
impressed by this level
okay well that should [ __ ] up the
building oh this is the mate level [ __ ]
and everything just breaks Reagan tore
through the entire building
I didn't as intended it'll be some time
before those he recovers from that never
got the employees out faith [ __ ] what am
i lacking cares for others Noah my
charming characters well we both share
occasionally
oh my god I mean but don't stick around
oh god oh my god without a fix it what
do I need to go okay we're sliding down
wow oh my god jump no oh my god what are
we going
is there helical what are we doing hey
get up
whoa make your way downtown walking fast
faces pass and I'm hope
ah right in the garbage
now what elevator yeah that seems safe
elevator in a crashing building all
right now we just got to go to safe
ground no problem
I feel safe already guys oh god I'm dead
Oh oh my god I did it let's go
oh my god how long is this zip fire my
fingers are falling up we did it
potential procurement okay okay now I
got in this episode there hope you're
present you're watching if you did go
ahead and leave a like support the show
I appreciate it and I'll see you bros
tomorrow with a new episode stay Oh
Mama's gonna smack your face try to come
from Jesus oh I see the hole I can see
the hole guys oh my god
Queen slain what